you voted for the 2017 movie she wanted
us to do an honest trailer for
and here's your number five choice
[Music]
shrek made you laugh how to train your
dragon made you feel
now dreamworks newest franchise will
make you question the very fabric of
reality
boss baby no seriously it's a weird one
meet boss baby his actual given name who
also happens to be a boss
a baby and a bossy baby version of alec
baldwin's bossiest roles
cookies are for closers coffee's for
closers only
you called do you need senor squeaky
[Music]
you called for ice cream sure here's two
scoops
but if you think that's all there is to
this kid's flick hold on to your
powdered butts for a sharp left turn
into madness
where the companies who manufacture
babies and puppies compete for the
limited amount of love in the world this
is war puppies are winning and babies
are losing baby core employees have
adult level intelligence but drink lace
milk to keep their bodies tiny
without that formula i turn into a
normal baby pacifiers that let you ask
to project your soul through physical
space i want you to suck it
and a memory wiping baby task force can
make you forget your own children
forget about the baby forget about the
baby
so if you think logan was the darkest
action movie that came out in 2017
or that ragnarok was the craziest you
haven't really listened to anything i
just said
has your child ever asked where babies
come from get ready to dodge that
question
with 90 minutes of lies that will take
years of therapy to undo
i wasn't born i was hired where babies
start life on a dangerous assembly line
get assigned their sex via pinball
machine and even though it looks like
women still get pregnant the baby shows
up in a taxi
but then what happened to the oh no this
can't be easier to explain than saying
mommy and daddy want to bone sometimes
no wonder kids are so messed up there's
more than just babies along for the ride
like tim the boy who shows you how
obnoxious only children can be
how would you like to have a baby
brother no thanks
i'm enough whose imagination borders on
clinical insanity
perhaps your parents need to be
enlightened with a great curse
and the villain francis francis formerly
known as
super colossal big fat boss baby who's
made a puppy so cute
it will literally steal a mother's love
from her kids
mommy man this movie is weird and we
haven't even touched on the part where
the seven-year-old gets hammered in
vegas
prepare for a film that will fill up the
diaper that was once your brain
as you question whether anything on
screen is real or not because tim falls
asleep at the beginning so it's all fake
but then the mom is actually pregnant so
it's real
but it's all from tim's point of view so
it's fake but the parents acknowledge
the baby is wearing a suit so it must be
real
he's like a little man but the action is
shown to be exaggerated so it's fake
but tim records the baby actually
talking so that's real but the parents
never hear the tape
so it's fake but the parents do hear the
baby talk so it's real
yes the baby's fine who was that but at
the end growing up tim says it's just
how he remembers it so it's fake but his
daughter is also a boss baby so it's
real
stomach movie i can't take it anymore
you've broken me
so if you're looking to put thoughts in
kids heads that they never would have
come up with on their own
you can't be fired from your own family
can you enjoy this acid trip that leaves
you with more questions than answers
but if you ever get overwhelmed sit back
and enjoy the office talk
i'm not gonna write a memo are you a
memo can
change the world but now i know that
memos are very important things
the one beetle song they paid for
blackbirds
take these broken wings to fly
and violence
[Music]
lots and lots of violence
hey stop it this is literally child
abuse
[Music]
story alec baldwin
toby mcgrier off randolph
steve buscemi i'm scary popping jaw
and the camino cloning facilities
glenn baby glenn boss
[Music]
this templeton is first class
why is it empty no one can afford it
that
that is more socio-economic commentary
than i expect from my talking baby films
the greatest teacher failure is
super leia in
come home to simple ricks
communism was just a red herring
my favorite superhero is iron track